determine whether the data in the table
is an example of direct inverse or joint
variation then identify the equation
that represents the relationship
so let's just think about what direct
inverse or joint variation even means so
if you have direct variation
direct variation so if y varies directly
with x it literally means that y is
equal to some constant multiple of x or
if you divide both sides of this by x it
means that y over x is equal to k so the
ratio between y and x is a constant and
you could go the other way around you
could also say that x is equal to some
constant not not going to be the same
constant times y or that x over y is
going to be equal to some other constant
so these aren't necessarily the same k
all i'm just saying is that it's a
constant relationship these are all
examples of direct variation
in or i should say inverse variation is
to some degree the opposite depending on
how you view the opposite and before i
even talk about that let's think about
the tell-tale signs of direct variation
if x increases y should increase so if x
increases let me do that in the same
yellow
so the telltale signs of direct
variation if x increases then y will
increase and vice versa the other
telltale sign is is if you increase x by
sum
by some factor so if you have x going to
3x
then y should also increase by that same
factor and we can see that with some
examples so you could pick a k let's say
that
let's say that k was 1. so if y is equal
to x if you take if x goes from 1 to 3
then y is also going to go from 1 to 3.
so that's all we're talking about here
and let me actually y should actually go
to 3 times y that's what i'm talking
about if you triple x you are also going
to end up tripling y
inverse variation
you have y being equal to some constant
times 1 over x so instead of an x here
you have a 1 over x or if you multiply
both sides by x you get x times y is
equal to some constant and you could
switch the x's and the y's around as
well for inverse variation now what are
the telltale signs well if you increase
x if x goes up
then what happens to y if x goes up then
this becomes a smaller value because
it's 1 over x so then y will go down
then y
will go down
and if you take x and if you were to say
increase it by a factor of 3 then what's
going to happen to y
well if you increase this by a factor of
3 you're actually going to decrease this
whole value by a factor of 1 3. so y is
going to go so then you're going to have
one-third of y so that's these are the
tell-tale signs for inverse variation
now finally they talk about something
called joint variation and this one you
won't necessarily see an introductory
algebra course but joint variation deals
with more than one variable so if i told
you if i told you that area of a
rectangle is equal to
the width of a rectangle times the
length of a rectangle this is an example
of joint variation area is proportional
to two is the proportional to two
different quantities so the main
telltale sign here for joint variation
frankly is you're going to be dealing
with more than two variables
joint
joint joint variation so when you look
at this example they're only giving us
two variables so you can rule out joint
variation just right from the get-go and
let's look at the tell-tale signs so as
x is increasing as x goes from one to
two what is happening to y y is going
from 12 to six so as x is going up by a
factor of two y is going is is is going
by a factor of one half or y is being
multiplied by one half as x goes from
one to three being multiplied by three y
is being multiplied or i guess you could
say is
is multiplied by one third so it's
definitely not direct variation as x
increases y is decreasing so it's
definitely not direct variation and then
really you could just rule out since
we've ruled out the other two you could
probably guess this is going to be
inverse variation but we can validate it
when x increases y is decreasing when x
increases by a certain factor y is
increasing by 1 over that factor which
so it's actually decreasing so if you go
from 1 to 3 if x is being multiplied by
3 then y
essentially becomes 1 3 of its original
value when x is 1
y is 12 when x is 3 y is 4. so we have
inverse variation at play now they ask
us identify the equation that represents
the relationship well we know with
inverse variation the product of x and y
need to be equal to some constant so if
we take x times y over here so let's
just let's make another column here let
me call this the x times y column well 1
times 12 is 12. 2 times 6 is 12. 3 times
4 is 12. 4 times 3 is 12. so clearly in
every situation x times y is a constant
and it is 12. so the equation that
represents the relationship it is
x y
is equal to 12 and that is clearly an
inverse relationship